le rassemblement national poursuit son
ancrage en bourgogne franche comté
il arrive en tête dans les huit
départements avec 26,3 pour cent des
voix l'extrême droite devance la liste
la république en marche modem qui
recueille 20,4 % des suffrages
la région suit la tendance nationale
la liste écologiste prend la troisième
place devant celle des républicains
c'est en milieu rural que l'extrême
droite a réalisé ses plus gros scores
notamment dans l'yonne et la nièvre
en revanche dans certaines grandes
villes le parti des manuels macron
résiste à la poussée du rassemblement
national
c'est le cas à chalon sur saône auxerre
ou encore dijon dans la cité des ducs et
la liste de nathalie l'oiseau arrive
largement en tête
le rassemblement national et même
dépassés par les écologistes
la grande surprise de ces élections
c'est le taux de participation
53 % pour la région bien plus que lors
des précédentes élections européennes en